all right everybody let's check out
social media for one last great story
before we go this is what I'm
liking for parents of toddlers good luck
first of all but you're lucky if your
kid finishes his piece not the case for
family in Buffalo though this is
2-year-old Levi who regularly din on
everything from watermelon gaspacho to
squid pasta which for a billion dollars
I couldn't get my kids to eat his Chef
dad curates the menu and post the
results on Instagram let's get these
Foodies in here say hi to Levi and his
dad Jack who watch on WKBW and Buffalo
New York hi y'all hi
guys oh my gosh Lei you're so cute so so
you're kind of Jack you're kind of his
private Chef right yes I am yeah cooking
has been my passion for the last 10
years uh I've worked in fine dining
catering and cook for professional
athletes and once Levi was born I knew I
wanted to share my love a food with him
so it started as early as making all his
baby food from scratch and now it's
progressed to cooking him scallops
chicken adobo brace oxtail and many
other dishes that even some adults
haven't tried his amazing reactions and
his curiosity when you know trying all
these Foods uh led me to document our
culinary journey together and that's how
cooking for Levi started we want to
inspire families to cultivate a healthy
relationship with food and it's been a
surreal experience with the amount of
love and feedback we've gotten from
everyone and it's allowed me to be a
stay-at-home dad in Levi's private
Chef you're you're you're getting
upstaged yeah so wait Levi so you have
something to to you're about to try
right right now foodwise yeah so he
actually helped prepare this with me
okay um he helped me cut up all these
fruits this is a we call it the ocean
par oh there you go oh that's delicious
looking yeah it's like a little fun
little idea to well if I made it look
like that my kids would eat it I was
like yeah so this is a Greek yogurt
that's colored naturally colored with
blue spirulina and then we grounded up
some gram crackers for the
sand and these are just a bunch of
different fruits why don't you give it a
try Levi oh my forget Levi I live at I'm
just kidding I'm like what that looks
delicious yeah maybe if I played it at
like a beach Disney World they eat
it oh my God I love it thank you so much
for inspiring us families this is
incredible a he's even sharing well
thank you so much Jack bye Leva thank
you for joining us I'm liking your post
right now and that's not all our season
long partner pilot pin makers of G2 and
the new G2 Edge the go-to pins of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to honor
inspiring families just like yours so
they're going to be riding yall a check
for $1,000 for a really great menu thank
you absolutely y'all have a good one and
thank you to all our guests this hour
Rob gronowski K ree Sydney M
Nicole Madison Logan and winfer you have
a great day and if it's not
[Music]
changing
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home